[Music]
[Music]
on the last episodes of the evolution of
hyrule we tackled the unified timeline
downfall timeline and ciao timeline that
is three down
one to go all that remains based on the
most recent official zelda timeline
published in hyrule historia
is the adult branch which in my opinion
is the most logical
consistent one of the whole bunch no
retcons no
old or obscure installments from times
before nintendo even considered a
timeline on this scale
and no weird inclusions which don't seem
to belong
the adult timeline is perfect three
consecutive games which all follow up on
each other without complicating things
whether or not you actually like every
installment is a different story but
it's hard to deny that this is the only
timeline where the events are crystal
clear and it actually feels like
nintendo had a road map in mind
again like the previous episodes i
recommend you watch part 1
first as that one explains everything up
until ocarina of time which like the
other branches the adult timeline
follows up on
so with that said let's get back to
business
[Music]
the first candidate on the list is the
game which got a lot of criticism upon
its announcement
only to quickly win over the hearts of
fans and critics alike the legend of
zelda
the wind waker the events of this game
take place hundreds of years after the
events of ocarina of time
however unlike the ciao timeline there
is no holiday trip
to termina no ventures or personal
journeys
outside hyrule and that is because in
this reality
the hero of time doesn't exist the wind
waker follows up on the future events of
ocarina of time that is to say after
ganon was sealed by the sages an adult
princess zelda sends link back in time
to relive his childhood essentially
erasing him from existence in between
ocarina of time and the wind waker an
event took place which
doesn't really have a name and is also
not listed on the official timeline
i've just decided to name it as it is
and that is ganondorf's
second invasion after sending the hero
of time
back in time adult zelda stayed behind
and hyrule now without a hero and with
ganon sealed inside the sacred realm
started rebuilding and recovering from
the devastation left behind after
ganondorf's tyrannical rule
as the only surviving member of the
royal family princess zelda is crowned
and becomes queen
is married and eventually has offspring
thus re-establishing the royal family of
hyrule
this time of peace was short-lived
however as it wasn't long until
ganondorf somehow managed to break free
from the sacred realm and similar to the
child timeline despite being sealed for
all these countless years he is still in
possession of the triforce of power
zelda still holds the triforce of wisdom
and since the hero of time ceased to
exist the triforce of courage has been
split into pieces and hidden across the
kingdom
its whereabouts unknown ganondorf once
again set his eyes on obtaining the full
relic
starting with a piece of wisdom and came
eerily close to his goal
together with his army he invaded the
capital and was literally at the
kingdom's doorstep
when after a desperate plea for help
from hyrule's people none other than the
gods themselves suddenly decided to
interfere
after instructing hyrule's populace to
flee to the mountaintops hyrule's
creators let loose a torrential downpour
flooding the kingdom beneath a giant
body of water later known as the great
sea
this event is also known as the great
flood king daphne's no hanson hyrule
ganondorf and his army remained beneath
the waves sealed inside a bubble at the
bottom of the great sea
and due to the power of the master sword
even frozen in time
among those fleeing to the mountains was
princess zelda along with her royal
caretakers
and as you can see from this painting
hanging inside hyrule castle are the
literal
ancestors of what will later be tetra
and her crew of pirates
man genes sure are a powerful thing in
this universe
hundreds of years pass by since the
great flood and the events of the wind
waker sees the ever so persistent
ganondorf once again break free as he
makes his way to the world above the
waves to continue his hunt for the
triforce
which now lies partially in the hands of
tetra who again is
zelda's ancestor and partially in the
hands of the king of hyrule
and as mentioned before the triforce of
power still belongs to ganondorf and the
triforce of courage is still in pieces
and lies hidden around hyrule
similar to the downfall and child
timeline we will use ocarina of times
map of hyrule as a source for comparison
since this is how we last saw the
kingdom before the timeline split into
three obviously as far as changes go
well
i mean the entire kingdom has flooded
all that remains of the once prosperous
kingdom
are the peaks of the highest mountains
which now serve as small islands where
the descendants of hyrule's inhabitants
have lived their
lives in the centuries since let's take
a look at hyrule's races first
this time as this will come in handy
once we start dissecting the lay of the
land
obviously we have the hylians which as
stated before are the distant
descendants of the people who once lived
in hyrule before disaster struck as far
as settlements go the large majority of
them live on windfall island which is
now kinda like the new capital
and the smaller group are living on
outset island which is also where link
and his family grew up
these hylians live a more simple life as
farmers and fishermen whereas on
windfall we see more use of technology
such as a giant windmill which doubles
as a lighthouse
alchemy photography and explosives then
we have dorito which are confirmed to be
the descendants of the zora
at least in this timeline now you might
be asking yourself the very logical
question of
why on earth would an aquatic race like
the zora evolve into birds when there is
literally water
everywhere now shouldn't this be
paradise for them and the simple answer
is that unlike the zora from termina
which are clearly saltwater based
since they live in and around an ocean
the ones from ocarina of time are in all
probability used to a freshwater
environment
they live in and around a big river
after all and ocarina of times hyrule
features no oceans
now maybe the zora can adapt to other
water types
but that would require time to adjust
clearly a giant
rapid flood is too big and sudden of a
change and would give them no time to
adapt however we have seen them being
able to live on land for extended
periods of time
relative to zoro's domain death mountain
would have been the closest peak
so they fled from the domain to the
volcano and with the help of the dragon
spirit value evolved into the rito
the gorons are almost entirely gone as
beings made up of pure rock
obviously they aren't exactly made for
surviving in the water as they would
immediately sink to the bottom and drown
however there is still a small number of
them traveling the seas as merchants but
there is no goron capital to be found
anywhere
it could be that there are more of them
who survived the flood and are now
living somewhere else
but we'll get into that later next we
have the koroks who are shown to be the
pure and true form of the four spirits
formerly known as the kokiri in ocarina
of time they have continued to live with
the great deku tree who is confirmed to
be the very same deku tree as the sprout
we saw in ocarina of time after beating
the forest temple the reason we know
this is because he initially mistakes
this link for the hero of time
who as mentioned earlier no longer
exists in this timeline
and lastly we have the gerudo well one
of them anyway
as far as we know nothing remains of
ganondorf's people they are never seen
in this timeline and must mean that they
were either
exiled after ganondorf was sealed were
wiped out during ganondorf's second
invasion
or maybe were not able to make it to the
mountains in time to escape the great
flood
with that said it's time to look at the
map now obviously the large majority of
hyrule is no longer visible
with it being underwater and all and we
don't even know how far the great sea
spans outside the borders of ocarina of
times map but we can still look at a few
individual islands and make some
estimates now the sheer amount of
islands we see here might seem
surprising but hyrule has always been a
very mountainous land
just look at the landscape of twilight
princess as an example and you can see
just how many mountains surround the
kingdom
in almost every direction mountains and
large hills can be seen in the distance
to get some proper orientation let's
start with hyrule's former capital
which lies here directly below the tower
of the gods though it bears little to no
resemblance to the castle we saw in
ocarina of time i do believe that this
might still be the same location
the way the castle stands on this rock
formation with only one bridge leading
in and out strikes a strong resemblance
to the way ganon's castle was built
which of course collapsed in on itself
at the end of the game so it could be
that the hylians rebuilt the castle on
top of the remains an alternative would
be that they moved the castle to lake
hylia since as we can see the castle is
surrounded by a giant lake
connected to a river and as we can see
lake hylia did have a small island in
the middle of it
we can also see ganon's tower in the
distance and is actually relatively
close by
and by the looks of it could be on the
edge of gerudo valley or even inside the
desert itself
the bridge leading to the tower crosses
this canyon very similar to the grudo
canyon found in ocarina of time
more interestingly if we go out of
bounds in the final battle arena where
we fight ganondorf we can see that the
tower is surrounded by desert
of course this is something we wouldn't
be able to see during the fight itself
but this proves that the grudo desert
does still exist
and is where ganondorf built his new
tower preceding his second invasion
furthermore we see no trace of the
temple of time anywhere in this timeline
instead the master sword now resides in
a secret chamber in the basement of the
castle
hidden underneath a statue honoring the
hero of time likely built under the
command of zelda
after she sent him back in time to
commemorate all he had done for the
kingdom
we do find a set of ruins to the south
east of the castle
approximately where the temple of time
would have been if we were to assume
that the castle was built on top of the
remains of ganon's castle
so could these be the remains of the
holy site and these other ruins in front
of the castle the remnants of castle
town
it's hard to say for sure but it's an
interesting thought nonetheless
regardless the temple of time is
obviously no longer around
either the hylians took it down after
ganondorf was sealed in order to get rid
of the entrance to the sacred realm
which the temple originally was
or it may have been destroyed during
ganon's second invasion after he broke
free from the sacred realm
whatever the case may be the master
sword had long since been moved to the
secret room in the castle's basement and
king
daphnis even comments on how ganondorf
never even knew about the existence of
this chamber
so moving the sword here seems to have
been the right call aside from being the
new resting place of the legendary blade
the chamber also serves as sort of a
memorial to the events of ocarina of
time it even depicts the original six
sages on the stained glass windows
now that we know where the original
capital lies we can start looking at
some of the islands and see if we can
find some original landmarks in the
world above
i won't be covering every island of
course as we would be here all week
besides most islands are clearly just
random previously unnamed mountain peaks
and nothing more
nothing we could cross-reference with
ocarina of times map but when we compare
the map of the wind waker to ocarina we
do see some familiar faces
death mountain has always been to the
northeast of the castle and on the great
sea
northeast of the tower of the gods we
find dragon roost island here it goes
without saying that this is most likely
the very same volcano death mountain has
historically always been the highest
peak in hyrule
and here too it stands as the tallest
island around aside from the tower of
the gods though that one is clearly
man-made we do see one additional
volcanic island but this one is very
small and so close to dragon roost that
it is likely an extension of the death
mountain region
ever since skyward sword we've seen that
there are other peaks surrounding the
volcano which also spew out smoke or
even lava
so the location definitely matches in
relation to the castle
the name change to dragon roost island
is also quite logical since we
already established in part one that the
name death mountain was given to the
volcano by the gorons who for many
millennia after skyward sword made their
home here
after the flood the gorons disappeared
from the volcano and now dorito formerly
known as the zora have been living here
for the past centuries alongside their
dragon deity
so they simply renamed it to dragon
roost windfall island is an interesting
one
it shares a similar soundtrack as
kakrico village but it's obvious that
the two villages are not the same
kakariko would have been located here
close to death mountain
however it is possible that the
inhabitants of windfall are descendants
of the people from kakariko the only
thing that doesn't make sense is the
location
since the village was so close to death
mountain you would think that this was
the most
logical escape option when the great
flood happened of course we don't know
how much time the people of hyrule were
given to evacuate before the water
started rising but perhaps the volcanic
environment of death mountain was simply
too dangerous and uninhabitable for the
highlands of kakariko
and instead they set off to a different
mountain to the northwest of the capital
alternatively maybe they did initially
flee to death mountain but again since
the environment wasn't suitable they
later sailed from dragon roost to
windfall and established their new town
here kakariko has historically been tied
to the shika
in ocarina of time it was originally a
shika village built by them
but because most of them were wiped out
during the hyrulian civil war the
village became predominantly occupied by
hylians and although the chica are
completely gone in this timeline and
are never seen again we do find one clue
of their heritage on windfall mrs mary
the teacher on windfall has what seems
like a stylistic depiction of a chica
eye on her outfit
this could mean that one or more
inhabitants of windfall have chica
ancestry or at the very least that a
part of their culture was preserved by
the hylians who fled to windfall since
the chica were already close to extinct
in ocarina of time
so in a way windfall and kakariko could
actually be connected in terms of their
culture and ancestry but geologically
they are completely separate from one
another next we have the forest haven
which matches with the location the
kokiri forest and lost woods would have
been located in relative to hyrule's
capital in ocarina
of time that is to say to the southeast
of the castle
it's not exactly clear how the forest
and deku tree came to exist on this
mountain peak since
i don't remember any big mountains in
and around the forest in ocarina of time
but then again the deku tree is a spirit
guardian
i guess he could have elevated the land
around him or grown a giant wooden
cocoon around it
i mean it is literally a tree within a
tree
so anything is possible when spirits are
involved and
honestly that's about it in terms of
islands we can use for reference
obviously looking for a lake or river
inside an ocean would be impossible so
lake hylia and the old zorus domain are
lost forever
and other places like london ranch and
the aforementioned kakariko village
would have also been completely
submerged
and none of them are visible from the
underwater hyrule castle either but if
hyrule castle was indeed still in the
same general area
as it was in ocarina of time they would
have been located somewhere around here
and although we do see the desert in the
out of bounds section
i showed earlier on the great sea we
don't really see anything familiar from
that province though i do find it poetic
that ganondorf's home base on the great
sea
is the forsaken fortress which is
approximately where the desert would
have been located to the west of the
capital
all the other islands even the ones
which play a pretty big role like outset
and great fish isle don't seem to have
any correlation with anything we would
be able to find in ocarina of time as
stated before they would have been
located on unnamed or even unseen
mountain peak somewhere
at the end of the wind waker the
underwater void which the old kingdom of
hyrule has resided in for centuries
finally collapses in on itself and the
last remains finally washed away
and buried beneath the waves officially
ending the existence of the kingdom
as we know it and that wraps up the wind
waker and we can finally move on to
phantom hourglass we will largely skip
over this game since it has
little to no relation to hyrule the
entire adventure takes place in a world
called the realm of the ocean king
because i only played this game once
a long time ago i initially thought this
was just a location outside the borders
of the great sea from the wind waker
somewhere but it is
actually another parallel dimension one
which link and tetra access through a
portal while aboard a mysterious ghost
ship while the rest of the crew stays
behind
and yes these are still the same
characters from the previous game and
only takes place a short time after the
events of the wind waker we know for a
fact that this
is a parallel world we can clearly see
the portal
time also moves differently between the
two dimensions since when the duo
returns to their own world they are
surprised to hear from the crew that
only about 10 minutes has passed for
them
i also quickly have to mention the
existence of this graph i only recently
discovered in hyrule encyclopedia i know
the canonicity of encyclopedia
is often questioned it does provide some
very cool tidbits of information
but it also makes some claims which fans
have debated or even flat out debunked
this graph
also depicts the realm of the ocean king
as a parallel world but i do find the
chart itself
a bit odd for instance i have no idea
why they chose to categorize these
worlds as
either parallel worlds or kingdoms
because some can be both
after all lorule is listed as a kingdom
but it's also clearly a different
dimension
we travel to it using rifts or portals
the same thing goes for labranow which
according to this chart is also a
parallel world but it's also
unmistakably a kingdom ruled over by
queen ambi i think it would have been
better to just classify them as
either parallel or non-parallel or
something oh and
by the way in part two about the
downfall timeline i stated that labrun
and holodrum are likely on the same
physical plane as hyrule but apparently
they are not in some ways this does make
sense seeing as link is transported here
by the triforce but it also raises some
questions considering that zelda and her
nurse made empire visit these worlds as
well either before
or after link arrives there i don't know
maybe portal travel was just
everyday business in hyrule but i
digress the realm of the ocean king is
structured very similar to that of the
great sea
a vast body of water with small islands
scattered across
hence my initial confusion that this was
on the same physical plane
in terms of races we once again find the
hylians like lineback and jolene
the anuki a brand new eskimo or inuit
type of race
the yuk also new to the series and who
are on bad terms with the anuki due to a
misunderstanding and interestingly
enough the gorons who have their own
island here
it's not clear if these are related to
the gorons from ocarina of time or the
few merchants we saw in the wind waker
but if they are it could be that the
majority of them fled to this dimension
during or after the great flood
not that this dimension is any better i
mean it's still a vast ocean but
oh well other than that there isn't
really much to say as
again this land has nothing to do with
hyrule or even the land surrounding it
it exists on a separate plane of
existence
it has its own locations and even its
own deity who watches over the land a
giant whale called oshas who has a lot
in common with the windfish from link's
awakening and i believe belongs to the
same type of leviathan deities
last up we have spirit tracks again this
game doesn't take place in hyrule
well technically anyway keep in mind at
the end of the wind waker the kingdom
was submerged for good however the
islands above the water still exist
so technically hyrule isn't completely
gone the kingdom is but places like
outset
windfall forest haven and dragon roost
are still there
however spirit tracks takes place on a
completely new continent one that
already existed for
who knows how long at some point in time
link tetra and the crew discovered this
new continent and their descendants
would go on to establish an entirely new
kingdom
this kingdom is often referred to as new
hyrule but other than the bloodline of
princess zelda it has no relation to the
original hyrule whatsoever
the continent itself isn't even called
hyrule only the kingdom does
the land is actually referred to as the
land of spirits of good
it even has its own history of events
preceding the time when the hylians
first landed here and established their
kingdom like the battle between the
spirit beings known as the lokomo and
the ancient demon by the name of maladus
although many characters we see in
spirit tracks have some very strong
resemblances to those from the wind
waker and phantom hourglass
nico is actually the only original
founder of new hyrule who is still alive
as far as we know everyone else
including link and zelda are descendants
seeing as how this is a completely new
continent it has very little impact on
the history of the kingdom of hyrule
in fact since this is the last game it
actually marks the end of its history
an old kingdom replaced by a brand new
one in faraway lands
we do see some of those good old hylian
naming traditions pop up once again
though
we have the obvious ones like hyrule
castle and hyrule field but also the
lost woods and kokiri village
there's no lake hylia and although there
is a volcano it isn't called death
mountain
what we do find aside from the hylians
are gorons who have apparently
also managed to make their way to this
new continent at some point
or already lived here before i don't
know
we do find zora as well though these are
the hostile kind akin to the ones we saw
in a link to the past
so probably not related to the rito from
the wind waker in any way the anuki also
make a return in this game and lastly we
have the lokomo who are more or less
divine beings similar to the sages
and yeah that pretty much sums up spirit
tracks as i said at the beginning of the
video the adult timeline feels like the
most consistent
and well-constructed sequence of events
three adventures which all follow up on
one another in a way that makes sense
chronologically a continuous voyage that
starts off with an ancient
legendary kingdom on its last legs and
is finally wiped from existence when its
purpose is fulfilled
in the end we see our heroes set sail
towards the horizon and
unknown lands in hopes of finding a new
future phantom hourglass serves as sort
of a side adventure
an unknown world in peril which they
happened to stumble upon on their
travels
after saving this world the same heroes
continued their search
until after years of traversing the vast
seas they finally find a new continent
where they establish a new kingdom where
their descendants will live on
and to pay homage to their lineage they
continue the naming tradition of hyrule
to pay tribute to the land which they
once originated from
it actually feels planned each game
picks up where the other one left off
we even hear a train whistle and the
sound of wheels on a track at the end of
phantom hourglass
proving that they already knew and
hinted at what the next installment was
going to be
[Music]
[Applause]
and with that we have reached the end of
the evolution of hyrule
for now at least i will eventually do
one final episode on breath of the wild
hyrule however it feels best if we wait
until after breath dwell 2 has come and
gone
as of right now we don't even know where
breath wild falls on the timeline hence
we have nothing to compare it to
we don't even know which version of
hyrule preceded this hyrule
or if it will even get a definitive
placement but the sequel could
potentially provide more information or
even totally explain
everything so until then i will keep
this series on hold for the time being
i hope you enjoyed this deep dive into
hyrule's history and geography
and thank you for joining me on this
journey and finally a big thanks to all
of my amazing patreon supporters and
channel members
we have two new faces joining the maze
so say hello to lux pro
and kyle thank you both so much for your
generosity
you guys are the best and that wraps up
the video i will see you in the next one
this is don
signing off and have a good one
[Music]
you